thank you to blinkist for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
we all know horseshoes are supposed to
be lucky from featuring in our favorite
marshmallow filled cereal to hanging
above barn doors to being on necklaces
and charm bracelets horseshoes are one
of the most recognizable good luck
charms in the world but why are they
considered lucky at all
before we answer that question here's a
quick word from our sponsor and that
sponsor is blinkist as consumers of
educational youtube i know my audience
is always interested in learning new
things and blinkist is a wonderful app
that helps you do just that blinkist
offers condensed summaries of the best
non-fiction books on the market and
gives you the most important points and
takeaways in 15 minute text and audio
explainers called blanks there are over
5 000 books in 27 different categories
to choose from from history to current
events to personal growth with blinkist
you can understand powerful ideas in
only 15 minutes
using blinkist i've just listened to the
summary of 1491
by charles c mann which describes the
history of indigenous americans
pre-contact with europeans and busts a
lot of myths that we still often have
about them
i think it's vitally important for us
who live on the american continent to
understand the history of this land
before columbus
so thank you to blinkist for helping me
find one of my new favorite books
right now blinkist has a special offer
just for you guys click the link in the
description to start your 7 day free
trial with blinkist and get 25 off of a
premium membership thanks again to
blinkist and now back to the video
if you grew up in a certain type of
church there's a chance you may have
heard the story of saint dunstan he was
a 10th century english clergyman who at
the pinnacle of his ministry became the
archbishop of canterbury their premier
bishop in england but before he was
ordained as a priest he was said to have
been a blacksmith the legend goes that
when dunstan was a blacksmith he was
visited by a man who asked dunstan to
re-shoe his horse
dunstan recognizing that the man was in
fact actually the devil calmly agreed
and when the devil wasn't looking
dunston hammered a still red-hot
horseshoe to the devil's hoof
rather than the horses the devil
screamed in pain and begged dunson to
remove the shoe
dunstan agreed on one condition that the
devil would never enter a house with a
horseshoe nailed above the door the
devil still howling in pain agreed and
wrote off vowing to keep the promise as
to not be burned again
this is a very nice story but i don't
have to tell you that it's just a legend
it seems to have popped up in around the
12th century a couple centuries after
dunstan's death but as good a fairy tale
as it is it is in fact not the origin of
the lucky horseshoe the charm goes back
further than the 12th century or even
the 10th century and the story of saint
dunstan and the devil was probably a way
of christianifying an older pagan
tradition so if it didn't come from
saint dunstan where did the tradition
come from
as with most folkloric traditions and
superstitions it's not easy to determine
where the lucky horseshoe started that
said scholars have a few theories that
are pretty well accepted
they can be broken down into the
horseshoe's shape the material and the
maker
first the shape horseshoes are in the
shape of a crescent crescents relating
of course to the moon have long been
seen as sacred and lucky symbols in many
cultures around the world crescents as
well as other two horned shapes have
been used as lucky amulets
second the material horseshoes were
traditionally made of pure iron and so
in the middle ages horseshoes were one
of the easiest sources of the metal
iron has had a long history as a
protective material in celtic and
northern european society it was said to
protect against malevolent spirits and
fairies
and in the middle east the metal was
said to ward off gin
the oldest superstition i can find about
iron comes from ancient egypt where iron
was known as devil's bone
whether this egyptian tradition inspired
the later superstitions is unknown but
the point is that it was ancient and
widespread
lastly the maker
in both greco-roman and germanic
mythologies blacksmiths were seen as
magical craftsmen hephaestus known as
vulcan by the romans was the god of
blacksmithing and forging so blacksmiths
unlike all other craftsmen had an
olympian to call their own
in scandinavia blacksmiths were known to
be magical due to their working with
fire and using it to turn what looked
like dirt to a lay person to hard metal
whatever the true origin of the
superstition is the idea of it being a
good luck charm as opposed to a talisman
to ward off mischievous fairies or
demons seems to be a relatively modern
practice probably starting in the 19th
century as all mentions of the horseshoe
before then is as a ward against spirits
or witches
and there you go a quick history of the
lucky horseshoe thanks again to blinkist
for sponsoring this video remember to
click the link in the description to
start your free trial and get 25 off a
premium membership don't forget to like
and subscribe bye